one of the traits that separates the
John Wick films from other hit action
franchises of its time is its relatively
spare use of visual effects in favor of
practical stunts Chad stahelski and
David Leech who co-directed the first
chapter are the co-founders of 8711
action design 8711 employs a wealth of
stunt in martial arts expertise and an
intricate prev visualization process to
experiment design and rehearse long
complicated fight scenes the John Wick
series is about showing off the Elegance
of practical stunt work with CGI only
taking prominence under specific
circumstances such as the motorcycle
chase in chapter 3 but the effects are
supporting the players not the star it's
a different variety of spectacle more
akin to martial arts films than other
modern American action spectacles